[Musique]
un barista une superbe machine un café
non
il existe d'autres options innovantes
sans caféine qui offrent le réconfort
d'une boisson chaude
maya et propriétaires des cafés de
standaard elle est aussi la fondatrice
de la compagnie meggen qui offrent des
boissons bio et vegan auquel il ne
suffit que d'ajouter du lait chaud la
première recette que j'ai créé ses la
betterave donc j'ai partie de la
betterave à cause de ses bienfaits et
impose que c'est sucré naturellement et
à cause de sa belle couleur on a envie
de la goûter cas soit chaude ou froide
donc et c'est de là que mes petites
recettes j'ai commencé à les contacter
en ajoutant seulement des produits
naturels
à travers toutes mes recettes souvent on
va me voir je ferme les yeux et je goûte
je me perds dans mes idées et je
commence à l'isic réalise à noter et
c'est vraiment du théâtre
à québec l'herboriste marie hélène
dufour s'est donné comme défi de créer
une boisson qui en plus d'être sans
caféine goûte le café c'est ainsi que
les siffle ont vu le jour la grande
difficulté c'est qu'on peut pas
remplacer une infernale qui a fait pis
c'est pas ça que je prétends non plus
moi ce que je veux c'est avoir des goûts
qui ressemble grillé ce puits avoir plus
de profondeur de savoir embauches
après des mois de tests elle atteint son
objectif créer une boisson chaude à
partir de racines et de petits fruits et
horrifiée et quoi la première
combinaison qui a fonctionné la faveur
convient d'avancer la canneberge la
canneberge avec des racines de petit
côté acidulé la racine de côté de terol
ça c'est mon produit peuple l'idée étant
simplement donc une cuillère à table
puis on met de l'eau chaude puis on fait
un fusil exact est ce que c'est
important pour toi au départ que ce soit
comme couleur café ou oui j'avais besoin
d'idéologie clos que ça soit noir qui se
ferait réconfortant comme le café salle
a une odeur aussi qu'il ressemble je
trouve le tir est conduit à s'engager à
super bon
la musique a inspiré marie-hélène pour
nommer sa gamme de produits le tango est
plus rond en bouche juillet noir c'est
comme mais après c'est ya un petit peu
de succès celle qui a déçu le blues
c'est parce qu'il ya déjà les jambes qui
pical comme les voir au que des
chanteurs de blues
bon ici nous avons le match est
[Musique]
donc ici on peut voir qu'il ya du plu
est en fait on le voit tous les grilles
élus isolés que je disparais dans les
textures que ça donne daily beast savoir
la hausse il va falloir trouver de
bleuets dans le breuvage mais il ya
aussi du chiffre mais pourquoi tu dis le
bleuet si on le goûte plus au final et
pour aller chercher le côté etc a fait
ses preuves à dire mais c'est par la
torréfaction qui l'ont lancé petit goût
le ça fait un peu noisette le jeu
profond de chambre sas et j'avoue que
c'est bon là
et marie hélène et maya ne sont pas les
seuls de plus en plus d'entreprises
d'ici se tourner vers la production de
boissons déhydraté à base de céréales
date chicorée champignons racines fruits
ou légumes les alternatives au café ne
manquent pas
à ce jour treize saveurs ont été créés
par maya dont le lat et à la pomme du
québec ici c'est plus des goûts basiques
sont pas axés sur les épées c'est très
prononcé aux états unis
et certains lattes et se démarquent par
leurs couleurs vives cette famille de
côté coco qq mois exactement vos goûters
la cannelle m et là la note finale c'est
notre coeur du mans c'est bien utilisé
allons-y pour la
salle aveugle je suis même pas certain
que je dirai à betteraves
c'est très dense très complexe et très
très bon aussi
[Musique]
sur sa route vers huy
le match on ne le ressent pas beaucoup
le côté amertume que souvent les gens
vont s'éloigner
et le côté via qui hélas feuilles de
stevia robin on la goûte pas donc parce
qu'elle est juste là pour éliminer la
question alors jaune rouge vert et bleu
qui naîtrait lavande de provence
ben
c'est goûteux l'avant à goutte l'avant
c'est très floral bois c'est ça qu'on
aime de la lavande et son côté bleuté
ç'a pris du temps pour développer le
marché parce que c'est un produit non
connue encore je sais pas si c'est de
l'art en turquie on aime seulement le
but de tamisage pas 12
[Musique]